[Music]
pan on
get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet and sour peppers
go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up trying
to slice a pepper
on the side is a nightmare there's the
center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look let's see one
now place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind pinky holding it down thumb
holding it nice and flat the flatter the
vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice
so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
and take your time
speed comes
the most important thing
is to get your technique right
red onion
now swing sour peppers
olive oil in
i'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's turn for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt
and pepper
add a tablespoon of sugar sugar helps to
break down the peppers quicker but
caramelize the onions frying them in a
frying pan perfect it's one of the sort
of basic essential tools of any kitchen
because it's so multi-purpose
great for sauteing
tossing
great for cooking fish and meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak in
you now start to see it's glistening in
a way that it's starting to caramelize
sugar is working beautifully
that's ready pour the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you see the sugar
it's worked as magic
turn down the gas and add a couple of
tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now i want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic
just roll the basil
almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds i want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now for the pork chops
i want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
cutting up in the pan they're we're
gonna cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the rind means
the chop stays flat and cooks evenly
[Music]
point the knife down
flip through just season them
beautifully
nice large
shards of pepper punch that through
lightly guaranteed that seasoning
is going to stay there
hot pan touch garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic
take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in
just starting to smoke
top of the chop
in
and lay away from me
nice
keep that heat in the pan
put the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork is staying nice and
flat
turn that over
i want a little bit of thyme underneath
there
start squeezing that garlic out i want
the flavor coming out
butter in
thin slices of butter
tilt the pan and baste
so i'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time i'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side useful
when they're that thick
between a half to four minutes each side
30 seconds from now they're gonna be
medium so i'm gonna take them out and
let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
a nice spoon
of these peppers the basil smells
incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your confidence is gonna shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet sour peppers
now the secret to whisking is a big
beautiful balloon whisk
the bigger the blue that meat sliding
down
juicy and incredibly tender